do you get jealous those people who
don't get nervous at all cuz I know I
did I want that because I know that I'm
ready to go I felt too comfortable in
one fight so then when I'm running to
the Octagon I'm like Oh Bob I'm like Bob
my legs don't feel good I'm like they're
they're really shaky I'm like I must
have ran too much this week I'm like I
can't I don't feel good I don't feel
good he's like dude just go fight he's
like just go fight like that's what you
do I was like all right that's easy Bob
you're not the one getting punched in
the head by a monster our next guest you
could argue the best fighter ever
certainly right now walking the planet
heavyweight division you know him you
love him he has a fight coming up here
UFC 241 I think August 17th UFC he's a
current heavyweight champion of the
world
friend of the show you can feel him on
the Twitter also at DC underscore MMA
needs a better handle than that Daniel
Cormier how are you sir
I'm doing pretty good man how much you
but the fighting styles okay I don't
know how effective it is you do have it
down low you look just like the Notre
Dame Hannah do you know where this stems
from though actually was reading up back
in bare-knuckle boxing I don't know if
you know this problem we were just
talking about hand injuries before the
show because they didn't want it would
break their hands right you had no
gloves so something like 80 to 90% of
the shots were body shots so apparently
they were more concerned with protecting
the ribs in their body and they would
just go for it but it still doesn't that
still doesn't explain the wrist turned
this way the wrist turned back I don't
hit it yeah well you know what honestly
when you're punching like Bob Bob always
tells me that right when I first started
I'd like to get close and I like to
punch to the body well we have a bad
habit of like wrapping the punches
around the side Bret cook always said
when you're punching you punch and you
bring the fist up to make it dig more
than just kind of slap so maybe that's
what it is so maybe that's why the fists
are like that cuz you dig up with it
maybe but this is definitely going to
become a gift Daniel Cormier doing this
dad is this you it's just that people on
the Internet are absolutely terrible
people they're horrible savages they are
savages
which is from you because some people
might look at you as as a savage fighter
we've had you on the show couple steps
okay let me ask you this whenever we
find some people who are you know
greatest in their field on this show and
I'm fortunate enough to get to sit down
and ask them some questions we'd Brian
Shaw world's strongest man like eight
times in the show let me ask you
objectively what is it that you think
makes you so much better than other
fighters because here's the thing and I
don't want to insult anybody out there
but like Josh Barnett for people so
people who aren't into an MMA this is
still something you probably want to
know if you want to be the best engineer
if you want to be the best singer
there's a gap with people at the top
Josh Barnett when you fought um Dan
Henderson these are mean guys Dan
Henderson you know I believe I believe
qualified for the Olympics Joshua net I
watched him beat people senseless and
great fighters is not an insult to them
I watched you throw them around like
they had never fought before what do you
think there's that gap I think certain
matchups like certain matchups like
benefits your style right and because
those guys are their base styles are
wrestling right in hi Russell - I feel
like the reason the gap was so big
between Dan and I was because I had
wrestled more recently right he was done
in 1996 I wrestled until 2008 yeah so I
think I was just a little more like my
wrestle was probably a little more sharp
as opposed to his but even still overall
I mean as a champion you've taken in
guys who are unbelievably could use
people again any Johnson where people
were scared for that fight because both
you had so much power
consistently what's the difference it's
just my approach you know my approach is
I'd train really really hard I try not
to leave any stone unturned I mean you
know I'm still about 12 13 weeks from
the fight and I just move they you know
spin bikes right yeah the air dyno time
is get a challange bike I got did hey
pedal it sounds like the massive one I
have like an epsilon bike was like the
one that's a little bit less expensive I
put it in my living room
I haven't all jive adult Schwinn from
Craigslist so I'm not judging exactly as
I am try to keep my money but instead I
can start getting in shape even on
thirteen weeks in the fight I'm starting
to
she and just to try to win eight weeks
hit I'm like a I'm ahead of the curve I
won't be playing catch-up so for five
weeks I'll just start preparing myself
to prepare for the fight and I think
that shows whenever I get in the Octagon
but I guess you know people like me the
laymen we look at it when you assume
that everyone at that top level right
you and your the have a champion we
assume that the number two the number
three guys at that point that they all
have good work that they all have good
trainers and then I mean sometimes you
have really competitive obviously title
fights that people can look back on or
controversial not with your recent
fights and certainly not at a known at
heavyweight I just wonder for something
that you think really separate do you
think it's work ethic
I think it's work ethic and I just think
a heavyweights they're a little bit
slower they're not as fast as the 205
long guys when I went to 205 I
immediately noticed a difference like
wow these dudes are a lot faster there
are a lot more athletic and I just kind
of I got it right away but I think it's
a number of things just my ability to
just work and in just being like being
like such a competitive guy like it
really is a great thing but it's also
like a curse because I can't turn it off
it's like in everything I do I'm like
ultra competitive I'm on that stupid
bike the other day and on the bike you
can spin and I don't know how to spin
I'm not a cycle I've never written well
first off they gave me like one of those
biker seats the little small seat yeah
this as well yeah I was right in the
middle it was right in the middle I was
like this is killing my ass give me a
big boy seat tsunami I'm riding the seat
that's like on those dudes bicycles like
with the big big big wide seat but I'm
riding and as I see my name on the side
like every now and again if my speed
picks up it'll pop into like a ranking
but with the other thousand people that
are on the app doing the class oh wow
and then I'm like going faster right
because I'm like [ __ ] I gotta win I
gotta win I'm exhausted and you're
beating some girl at soul cycle maybe
Trista hey I'm beating Trista from San
Luis Obispo
her little girls like on her bike like
her kids playing on the bike yeah
Trista's profiles I'm like trying to win
bad yeah at all well does that does it
not bode well for you then since you've
talked about retirement at least here
somewhere in the next couple of fights
what do you think it's gonna be hard to
kind of come down from being at that
hyper competitive level who I think
that's the problem
you don't know like that's the problem I
just don't know I don't know what my
life looks like after competition
because the first time I learned to
train for something at the highest level
I was 15 years old right I went and
wrestled in the World Championships 15
and 16 year olds for the United States
and I was like and then it's just been
that for 25 years I've never had a time
where I wasn't preparing for something
so maybe it'll just be like the
television stuff I do and all that and
maybe try to find that competitive safe
space through my children and my
wrestling I I don't know I really don't
know what's gonna become of Daniel
Cormier when there is no when there's
nothing to chase like I I've always had
something to chase right I love the
chase does that does that scare you at
all a little bit it's a little scary
like cuz I was talking to my wife
yesterday and I was telling her about
Les Miles right he was coach at LSU at
Oklahoma State Pryor didn't LSU and then
he got fired from LSU and then his wife
said that he would just he had an
apartment in town that he had an office
where every day he still went to work
because that's what he had to do he
would look at recruiting boards you
would look at this and it was like he
wanted to stay sharp because what if he
decided to coaching it and he did now
he's at the University Kansas but he
went to work every day so for me I was
talking to Selena the other day I was
like do I get an office in town the
handle all my wrestling and my
television stuff or did I do something
in the house and just secure a room that
has just work stuff to where I can focus
all this energy on something new because
I need something and I'll coach my
wrestling I'll go to a K and I'll coach
to help with the younger fighters but I
don't know uh I don't I don't I don't
know what I'm gonna dumb I'm it's a
little bit scary but its life you know
yeah I think it's almost similar to in a
lot of ways in
all belittling opposite people who are
veterans who come back but people who
come back from sort of war I mean it's
just a super super high intensity and
they have a little bit of trouble
sometimes reintegrating because they
don't know what it's like to not be
operating on that level and yeah see at
the center with a lot of performers I
was just talking with Ted Nugent about
it the reason a lot of comedians I think
turned to drugs and alcohol is because
they're performing - you know 11:30 at
night you know and that's also a high
that's really a lot of yet let's that's
scary to do - and it seems like the
people who really make are people who
learn how to deal with that transition
well I was reading the story on Dewayne
Wade the other day and he said something
about he has to see a psychiatrist
because he's done now because for I
don't know how long he played in the NBA
18 years it was always like a schedule
and now it's like there is no schedule
you know you got to go to the grocery
store and do like normal people things
and it's just it's not it's not that
easy but for me I do a lot of that stuff
in my day to day life right I love going
to grocery store it's like my favorite
thing and I live in a small town so it's
fine people don't really mess with me
all that much they see me so much like a
champ like hey what's going on but I
just need like in terms of my
competitive drive is why I'm gonna need
something to really because otherwise my
wife's like go to the gym do it like
you're driving me crazy with your
brother too much all this energy and
you'll know what to do with it so maybe
you just take up competitive couponing
combine your love for grocery Anna a
coupon at or you know like hey you can
golf for a long time I got a bad back so
I don't know if the back will allow me
to get a good golf swing but maybe I'll
like start taking some like probably get
a probably golf coach or something just
play golf but see that's your
competitive spirit again you can't just
go play golf for finally making a
private golf coach and then I'm gonna
shark guys in the golf course and tell
them like my first game but not mental
private lesson because the man ya old
dudes know like old dudes I'll just
start with all the old is doing like oh
yeah how's this guy like 60 oh my first
game was against him you want to play
who can drive further contest you can
enjoy to grow old I'm old you know judge
I would pay to see that a pro-am tour
and you with a cigar in your mouth next
to Alice Cooper he's the best he's the
best celebrity golfer in the world that
was very per is oh it's not even closed
yeah he got real
it's not even close he's a great book
biography called golf monster and it's
just one chapter autobiography next
chapter golf tips and and he got sober
yeah he got sober playing two 18-hole
rounds of golf every day every day
he played 36 holes a day every day every
day Louise
yeah so I was trying to do nine holes
day I was like oh I get so bored I'm
like he's over because I was so bad yeah
I know I what once the one time I did it
and it went so long I like man people
who play this all the time must really
hate their wife because like I feel like
they're going home to an abusive wife
was just throwing shoes at them you know
like I'm gonna go golfing sweetheart so
okay so that's always interesting
meaning that we're this gap but let me
ask you this on the flip side because
obviously you're heavyweight champion
the world have you ever been on the
other side of it particularly like you
said when you were 15 starting out in
wrestling or anything where you felt
like oh my god I'm really good but
there's this huge gap between me and
this next guy was that no I mean I think
I've had that more than anyone in the
world
you know honestly like and it's not like
the huge gap but I've had to compete
against like the great right like yeah
when I was in college it was Cael
Sanderson who was a hundred and this
dudes the only undefeated College rest
of all time I don't know Peck from hell
is zero losses you know he's just
fantastic a lift Olympic champ and he
beat me I lost I think I lost like 11
times in college and he beat me eight of
them right so I wouldn't lose to anybody
else but him and then um did he ever had
an ankle pick on you every single how
you go killed why about following you
know it's funny I what I would do when I
would start grappling cuz there was no
there were no schools near me I would
just watch it go okay who's the best at
this let me watch it and it watched his
tutorial in the ankle pick and it's one
of those things that maybe this
sometimes creates the gap you realize
afterward because he kind of kept it a
secret it was all the setup where he
would be holding if it was you know for
example your right hand
he'd behold he do kind of a not really a
snap down but the gap from your right
wrist to your ankle might have been four
inches at that point and that yellow do
so we drop and grab it and I will try to
kick away and he would just run down
grab my poor ankle so all of a sudden
I'm like sitting on the ground and I'm
like got me again with it but it was him
and then before the Olympics in the
semifinals of the Olympics I wrestled
this kid this Russian kid named gets a
LOF who was a dude was a five or six
time world champ two-time Olympic champ
right he beat me and then when I got the
fighting it was john jones so it was
always like I always had the people that
people consider maybe the greatest but
for me that's what allowed me to chase
things at such a high level because like
I said I love the chase like I don't run
away from it it's what kind of drives me
to be Who I am
right what would you say if you had to
pick your greatest obstacle that you've
had like if you had to pick one to
overcome I mean either personally or
professionally who's been the toughest
one of all of all the best or anything
anything that you struggled with that
you would say you know you've really you
really had to plow through to become you
know the champion that you are I think
it will I think I understand he was the
Sanderson thing cuz it was so early in
my life right like as a 20 year old kid
it's easy to go you know I didn't
accomplish my goal tonight it was all I
wanted to do was the n-c-double-a
champion I didn't but then to be able to
dust myself off and in two years later
being on the world team right like to
take to understand those lessons as a 21
year old kid and then apply them to
where I'm second in the country in a one
but bio three I'm top five in the world
right it was like I took those lessons
and I applied them to how do I get
better and maybe I don't have to climb
this mountain but there are other ones
that I need to try and climb in it was
all lessons I learned from Louis
Anderson so many times what lessons
would you say you learned most from from
kill Sanderson what did you go back in
your mind and say man I made these
mistakes or did you go back and say I
didn't make mistakes he was just better
who's better
I can easily say that about him I can
say about this all off the Iranian those
guys were better you know I didn't make
mistakes to get beat there was one time
the scene in my senior year me and
killer in the finals I take him down
make the score like five four with like
a minute half left and I go to let him
go because I have to take him down again
and I like for a second night pause and
right as I pause he just turned around
and grabbed my legs and then I fell now
it's seven four oh now I was like oh my
god I can't believe I just did that you
can see me on the edge of the mat just
like shaking my head like oh no I can't
believe it but it was it was just that
that moment was probably the most
difficult one I had to deal with it was
my last match so would you say it's
harder to deal with mistakes that you
could have avoided or would you say it's
harder to deal with a problem where you
just have to accept that someone might
be better it's out of your control I
think if you I think if you make
mistakes it's like gosh why didn't I
just stay the course right even with me
and Jones fought the last time we were
fighting the first fight we fought
through three competitive rounds before
at the fifth round I was exhausted I
didn't fight well he won second fight
were going through two rounds it's one
round apiece first round was a was very
close second round I won third round
we're kind of going good again and but
then I'm like talking right I'm like not
in 100% focus then I get kicked in the
head but then and so I have to deal with
that like that those are the ones that
you don't live down very easily like
right I'm just like man if I would have
just stayed laser focus I don't know
what could have happened right but it's
like oh I'm in there like I'm like okay
this is going better than I could have
imagined and I started getting too loose
and that's not me I'm not a guy that
talks trash in the fight I get the job
done and in that moment I didn't and I
ended up paying the ultimate price
you're not like a Diaz brother in
research know what what is done stuff
like that right and I don't do that but
then he was trying to hit me and I was
seeing and moving and I'm like what was
that I'm like no like that won't happen
and then he went to a position that in
the first fight he did a lot of and then
I defended it because we have a pair of
and I'm like no not this one not this
time right but I should have never did
that I should have just stayed laser
focus as I always do do good and do bad
and then I would've did much better you
know so those are the ones that stay
with you at night also you should have
done some anavar
Deanna Volta even the playing dollar
should her just see the play I would
imagine the same thing with the Russians
you wrestled against you've had you had
your fair share of matches against human
pin cushions there's a few huh there's a
few little differences in the way that
we approach the competition but
ultimately I'm in there it's my job to
get the job done you know let me ask you
this because I think a lot of people
watching it's often it's easy for people
to sort of distance themselves from
people who are who are great and that
could be not only fighters but it could
be you know business owners people who
are super wealthy or maybe people who
they see as super skilled intelligent so
they maybe think that you're not afraid
or you don't face the same kind of
adversity and that sort of absolves
people of coming up with solutions
themselves so let me ask you this
directly before a fight right you're
looking across like you're gonna have a
rematch for example with steep Amy oh
[ __ ] she was a killer in his own right
but before any fight are you what's it
what do you feel what's going through
are you scared are you nervous are you
calm is it a blur oh it's so
nerve-wracking it's Steve it's so
nerve-wracking like if if I've done it a
lot though like last year where I fought
in January July and then again in
November
I feel the nerves aren't as strong when
I fought in 15 I fought three times and
then I didn't fight from October all the
way to July i'ma fight Anderson Silva
who hadn't fought and he only came on
two days notice and I felt like it was
the most nervous I've ever been in my
life really because I it wasn't normal
anymore I wasn't on autopilot but I go
back there and mm-hmm the whole time
digging and I went to college you know I
probably could have got a job and how
many times did I go you're not homeless
you're a pretty success you do have a
job get it I was like how many times
when I should went right to end up here
where I'm about to fight some dude three
hours like yeah this dude wants to take
my head off in three hours right and
then so I'm nervous I'm like so nervous
and then once I started moving and I
started like taking any environment I
got some breathing exercises and I lay
down and I rest now this is music and
what I really like once I start getting
into the environment and then the moment
Steve I hit that that I hit the curtain
like my music comes and I'm walking with
my team and I'm like and I'm like okay
there's no other place I'd rather be
like this is this like this is just the
best so for you at someone when you
leave the curtain so by the time you get
in the Octagon you're not nervous
anymore oh not at all I'm like oh let's
get started I'm like the moment I get
the moment eight things they always say
this they go what like where I'm in the
back and I'm hitting pads and I'm moving
and I'm just kind of like doing my thing
and then there's always the guy from the
UFC that goes we're walking in five
minutes champ and then he leaves and he
comes back alright DC it's time to go
and then once they do that I'm my
alright man let's go do this thing you
know like eight weeks I've been
preparing for this eight weeks I've been
preparing myself to prove that on this
night I'm better what right yeah it's
interesting though because some people
don't feel that way like we just had Ted
Nugent on the show recently we've had
George st. Pierre on and we've had we've
had Chael with it that we've had a bunch
of different people on the show and some
people say no I don't get nervous I love
it and some people get really nervous no
I was I'm like you before every time I
do a live show even before I often do
this show I get so nervous and before
particularly big live shows where I've
got to do an hour an hour and a half
I'll if my wife is there she'll tell you
I always have this moment where I go
I've forgotten everything I don't
remember and then I usually have to go
poop when you're doing stand-up you're
doing a live show you can go to the
bathroom but you're all wrapped I've got
to imagine that that happens a lot in
the waiting room every time right you go
clean then here's my deal I get drug
tested every fight so I hold it I go in
there with a full bladder every time I
piss early I piss when I get to the rear
by three hours I'm like then Bob's off
do you need a pee I'm like nope I'm home
until after the fight I'll piss in that
Cup because otherwise I'll be there for
hours I'll be there for hours trying to
pee and I'm like yeah are the waiting I
go in there and I fight and then
afterwards I try to go pee my drug test
we hadn't get out of it it's a trend you
know the only time I ready to take a
drug test never turn this story quarter
black you know it was an act this is a
true story no it was a job where I was
supposed to call kids as Santa Claus so
parents would you know send you the
letters to Santa and I would call them
ho Jimmy you been a good boy this year
and since I'd done voice acting I
thought this is an easy way to pick up
work I had to drive out three counties
over to go do a drug test
and I'd gotten the job and then I peed
in a cup and they pulled it and I have
no idea why to this day never done drugs
I have no idea why but something tells
me that I must even that Cup and they
said you were unfit to be Santa Claus
give me the job I had the job and then
they pulled it back and they wouldn't
return my call so I'm wondering if I
pissed house or something I've done
drugs I have no idea what happened hey I
was freaking out today because like I
took a you SATA test a few weeks ago and
I was like man I haven't gotten my
result back yet
I'm like what's going on and I'm like
calling Cassandra I'm like hey what's my
you SATA password and all this stuff and
she goes she gives it to me and then I I
uh I she goes when was the last time I
said I had one in April it's a 10 13
days for the result and she goes well
when did you test this time I'm like the
15 I'm but like isn't it the 31st
she's like dummy it's the 28th it's been
13 days exactly she's like you're
freaking out for nothing I was like like
yeah because I want to know like what
the hell's going on my desk result like
it does not matter if you know you're
not doing anything wrong getting tested
is like give me the results I know that
everything's fine she just told her you
thought it was a leap year and sign up
the phone we thought it's not my fault
that I'm doing the equation before you
do I was just wrong and I live it I live
in the future like I'm like coming back
to have this conversation like let me
ask you this do you ever get jealous of
people like we hear legendary stories of
people like Chuck Liddell who didn't get
nervous do you ever get jealous those
people who don't get nervous at all cuz
I know I did I want that because I know
that I'm ready to go because it's not I
don't think it's fear I think it's more
competitive nerves like the competition
inside of me is like stewing you know
it's like it's more competitive it's not
necessarily I don't think it's fear it's
a little bit but it's like it's more
competitive and if I feel too at ease I
get I start talking myself I felt too
comfortable in one fight so then when
I'm running to the Octagon I'm like Oh
Bob I'm like Bob my legs don't feel good
I'm like
they're they're really shaky I'm like I
must have ran too much this week I'm
like I can't I don't feel good I don't
feel good he's like dude just go fight
he's like just go fight like that's what
you do I was like all right that's easy
Bob you're not the one getting punched
in the head by a monster I had one of my
best performances ever but I tried to
talk myself out of being as ready as I
was because I didn't feel that thing in
the pit of my stomach that I normally
feel I've got some really weird
superstitions
like seriously okay I don't like Mike
like I have a chair in my locker room
that nobody can touch because I put
everything the way it's supposed to be
from my room the night before the fight
go my shorts my fight shorts my cup my
t-shirt my hat my shoes and my socks it
stays there it goes from that chair into
my backpack into the arena don't touch
it don't touch the chick and if someone
judge says you start screaming water
burn baby and hitting we're not one time
somebody went and touched I was like
don't touch it cuz I believe that leave
it writer this is out as it is there for
reasons no like dude calm down I'm like
yo don't touch the stuff
that up it's a good idea it's like my
hand I'm from Louisiana so my mom always
told me you left hand itches you're
getting money right hand starts to itch
you're giving away money it's like money
passing through your hands that's what
she always told me weird Louisiana thing
every time I fight I'm like just looking
at my hands and like start itchy because
it means I'm gonna win a Steve everytime
it itches I win
wow it just all do fight camp but if it
starts doing this I'm like well I better
run more I just start freaking myself
out yeah that doesn't sound like it
should be necessarily your method of
period izing your training it sounds to
me like it can lead to over trips like
no I gotta run five more you already did
18 today it's not it she'd like me to
run more cycle with high so I go run
it's crazy
Louisiana I'm like very superstitious
and I know it's so ridiculously if you
go fight like in Brazil or Mexico like
they have a lot of UFC cards no you
could have just picked something up
that's skin born and you don't know
never I've never I've never I told him
I'm never fighting international I was
in Brazil last two weeks ago and Michael
Bisping was going to do a movie
in South Africa as he's leaving they
told him he couldn't go to South Africa
because they were saying that he's been
in Brazil more than 15 hours so he had
to go get like a yellow fever test or
something so this dude was on a freaking
36-hour trip to so many different
countries just to try to get to the set
of his movie because he went to Brazil
was a scary place man oh I know I was
there for like five days and didn't
leave my hotel like the beach was like a
hundred yards away from my room and I
was just staring at it longingly like it
would be so fun to walk up sarod like
did you heavyweight champ of the world
like yeah did Dominick Cruz is just
sitting there on the beach bombs he's
such an angry little guy like I wish
they would somebody sitting at a table
at the beach vibe still eating lunch
gosh well yeah it's actually pretty a
pretty good comparison there because you
guess what people on the internet going
like oh people wouldn't do that to me in
real life it's like the heavyweight
champion of the world doesn't want to go
to the beach in Copacabana because he
knows that a knife is still more
effective and they will have defeated
our gun because yeah they they fear
monger to me right it's like my wife
every morning my wife gets fear monger
about Good Morning America
is my wife every morning she's like oh
Daniel did you hear about this did you
hear about this I'm like why don't even
watch the news if all they're doing is
making you terrified of living life like
don't watch the news if it's that bad
but they told me in Brazil don't bring
anything nice right so the watch I
brought it was a G Shock watches $50
shock watch to go on television with
because I was so scared he said they
said two years ago the UFC was at that
same hotel they went to the beach and
they got robbed armed gunmen that all
the UFC staff in got him for their cell
phones everything else they may have had
the whole staff feel like all the staff
like all the support staff that went to
the beach they were they said it they've
got the grip they said there's on the
beach they've got great cold beer and
it's like you want to go hang out the
beer may cost you first there's
definitely costing yourself be safe in
your room or go across and have a nice
cold beer and run the risk of somebody
trying to rob you well remember I jail
talked a bunch of trash I was doing his
fighting Anderson Silva they had to have
a little full armed security detail they
would chant out they were gonna kill him
and they meant it they do it every time
don't like when you walk sit over to the
Octagon it's a it's what they say to
their uh to their opponents you're gonna
die yeah you're gonna die yeah twenty
thousand Brazilians yelling at and
Portuguese that's them intense though
I'm not fighting it well you know that's
a big difference I want to ask about
this in the United States in Brazil they
always cheer for their guy always in the
United States we're the only country
where we'll cheer for the other guy if I
think he's a good guy
it's so crazy I you should have saw when
Chris Weidman beat Anderson Silva I was
standing there with like three American
flags like just waving them right
because quite minute one but the crowd
was totally crazy it was driving me
crazy my computer's got 1% is gonna die
oh no hurry oh no all right well I've
had a bunch of other questions I want to
ask you about life uh okay so uh let me
go through this pretty quickly the fight
is let people know when the fight is
against 217 UFC 241 August 17 ok and
what do you plan on on doing after that
fight is this gonna be your last one do
you think or do you want another crack
at it Jones at heavyweight it's been
discussed I don't know but I'm gonna be
in Texas so I might come see you guys
I'll be attention I'm gonna guest
speaker at Texas A&M we have to fight
maybe down there baby I'll come see you
guys while I'm down in Texas that would
be really nice and then we can get
hopefully more than a middle-of-the-road
answer on retirement and whether you're
fighting Jones and though we can pry it
out all right 1% so Daniel come let me
give them your Twitter is a DC
underscore MMA again that's you if it's
a horrible handle and it's the same
horrible handle for every social media
platform we've been through this it's
not really a nickname it's just an
initial it's really not just my initials
creative guy that's ok it's better than
getting nickname is something you hate
which often happens in this sport hey
that's why you pick your own nickname
but I gotta tell you something no you
look
pumped-up since the last time I saw you
how many pushups are you doing deal none
this is just this is just fat see you
like you can just this is just I'm
thinking of competing as a woman in the
IP in a powerlifting Federation all
right mr. Cormier I know you're busy 1%
say hi to mr. cook I'll give him a ring
we must go thank you sir Godspeed on the
fly thank y'all for having me again it's
always fun hey there Here I am drinking
from my mug in a button-down how often
do you see this never so do me a favor
and yourself click one of these videos
playing in one of these boxes here or a
subscribe hit a notification bell also
because subscriptions don't really mean
a whole lot if you really want to
support the show join my club if you
don't then there's no helping you